oh là là là ils sont déjà là
excusez moi mais il était temps que
j'arrive j'ai failli vous faire perdre
votre temps et est en plus pour rien
parce que moi aujourd'hui je n'ai pas le
temps de rester non non je n'ai pas le
tort parce qu il fait bien trop beau
temps alors j'ai décidé de prendre mon
temps pour aller me baigner ah non pas
par un bain dans ma baignoire gelé déjà
pris ce matin non un bain dans la mer
bon allez excusez moi mais aujourd'hui
je suis vraiment obsédé par le temps
d'ailleurs comme dit un proverbe le
temps perdu ne se rattrape jamais
évidemment sauf avec ma machine à
remonter le temps vient pas notre
proverbe dit d'ailleurs le temps c'est
de l'argent
ça je ne sais pas si c'est vrai bon
d'ailleurs j'espère que vous passerez
agréablement votre temps même en mon
absence bon allez moi je parle je
parlais et pendant ce temps là le temps
passe à une vitesse
petite malle magique ne parle pas à
n'importe qui en mon absence salut
casimir comme on active je n'ai pas le
temps je n'ai pas le temps ou à l'arrêt
qui pourrait - prendre le temps de me
répond non ça me prendrait beaucoup de
temps
chez nous allons résister mais
ça alors il a filé
je lis je les y avoir un oui françois je
sais ce que tu vas me dire là je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec toi casimir
exagère sans peut le dire non mais
vraiment tu t'assures il choisit mal son
moment pour s'en aller celui-là
dire que les enfants l'ont attendu toute
la journée et je sais julie je sais il
comptait beaucoup sur lui pour s'amuser
excusez le vous savez il vous aime
beaucoup quand même oui oui et puis si
cassini répartissez qu'il avait
certainement quelque chose de très grave
de 2,2 très important à faire
ah vivement qu'il revienne parce que
pour nous aussi le temps est lourd au
delà la wii eh ben et ben voilà voilà
voilà voilà
voilà
il faut absolument trouver quelque chose
à faire pour amuser les enfants tu
trouvais ça tout seul toit
et gilly va vous chanter sa chanson mais
non tu fous je n'ai pas répété françois
va faire un jeu avec vous non non non
j'ai rien prévu enfin
excusez nous on doit pas avoir l'air
malin on n'est pas très en forme c'est
ça arrive
bravo way
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait bien fait julie
j'ai une idée nous allons demander à la
malle magique de nous aider a dit ce
faire les enfants ça c'est une vraie
génial 1520 sauver balle magique viens
ici
et les sourds de quoi maj il vient ici
immédiatement
il ne bouge pas enfin c'est pas comme ça
qu'il faut faire jolie et gentille
magique
françois et moi nous serions très flatté
de nous entretenir avec toi
ça n'est pas plus difficile que ça
fasse alors bravo julie bravo et bien
gracieuse mêle magie gracieuse vous
devez nous aider amuser les enfants
pour nous montrer que tu nous as compris
ouvre un peu ton couvercle
juste un peu
aller au bout tu vraiment agaçant
bravo julie bravo beau but du la brusque
et enfin elle est repartie elle s'est
vexé c'est normal rejoignant leurs
adorables malle magique as tu compris ce
que nous attendions de toi
je viens voir
je crois qu'il n'a rien compris du tout
non il me semble que cette mâle né
magique qu'en présence de casimir et
sans lui et bien elle redevient une
malle ordinaire le coup de françois elle
est quand même venu à nous tu as déjà vu
des mâles ordinaire qui se déplaçait
tout ça toi bah non non non bien sûr je
t'assure que si casimir et elle a bien
cette malle parlerait françois elle lui
a écrit un petit mot
notre voisin
je trouve que même son casimir vous
arrivez très bien à 10 heures les
enfants
je la trouve très bien moi cette même
logique finalement
c'est fantastique elle a apprécié notre
gaieté notre imagination alors esprit
inventif notre notre sens aigü poussée
du comique ça je répète le bravo elle
est très très très très bien ah mais
attends ya une suite
en effet le spectacle de votre panique
sans casimir est vraiment du plus haut
comique
heureusement comme on dit que le
ridicule ne tue pas il
[Musique]